friendship in reverse and the
protagonist named the protagonist we
won't blame you if you lieutenant with
more questions than answers
the algorithm is the MacGuffin of tenets
which in filmic terms means the thing
everyone is after many people die trying
to locate it and we're told it holds the
key to Earth's destruction but what
exactly is the algorithm one is a
Formula created by a scientist in the
future that allows time inversion and
two it is a physical doomsday device
currently disassembled into multiple
Parts which when assembled has enough
power to destroy the planet as explained
by a scientist named Priya who believe
the algorithm was so dangerous as she
created a physical copy that was then
dismantled and hidden all over the world
in the past there are nine nuclear bars
line bombs nine sets of the most closely
guarded materials in the history of the
world in Senate we see the race to
locate these dismantled pieces the clear
villain is SATA who wants to reassemble
the device in order to destroy the world
throw instructions by a future Source
the main hero of the film typically
known as the protagonist in any story is
actually referred to within this film by
that very title the protagonist
my part
I'm the protagonist of this operation he
wants to retrieve the algorithm to
prevent the use of the device for the
destruction of the world because he
trusts that other and better outcomes
still remain possible the protagonist
meets the character of Prayer of Four
Points in the story during which he
relays important information to him one
piece at a time ultimately priya's plan
to stop SATA involves allowing the
madman to locate and assemble all the
pieces to the algorithm but then to stop
him from using it which is a bold move
to say the least luckily the gamble pays
off satyr is defeated and everyone moves
on with their lives however in the
film's closing moments during a final
meeting between the protagonist and
Priya he kills her but why well it turns
out that Priya had made plans to try and
kill cat evidently believing such action
would preserve and protect a highly
confidential actions which have been
taken by tenet however before she could
pull off the Sterns the protagonist
kills her to save cat and her son who
may actually be neon as it turns out the
protagonist has Empire in the past and
is actually the one responsible for
tenets meaning that all along he wasn't
working for her she was working for him
on a first viewing of tenants it's
possible to miss the parts when Neil
dies to be fair the final battle is
difficult to follow repeated viewings
make it clearer also it seems so how
does he die well drawing that Giant
action finale at Styles 12 the
protagonist makes his way to the hypo
Center where sata's man is busy lowering
the algorithm into a massive hole next
to a corpse with a familiar red tag
lying on the other side of a locked gate
sata's man's possible protagonist and is
about to shoot him when the corpse Rises
takes the bullet and opens the gate in
Reverse turns out this was Neil only we
didn't know at the time because the
person was wearing a mask and the scene
is intricate with seemingly simultaneous
scenes of Neil driving a Jeep outside
what we come to realize is that there
are multiple Neils performing multiple
actions in multiple directions some
needles are inverted While others are
moving forward it turns out Neil was
also the man who saved the protagonist
at the Kiev Opera if that weren't enough
Neo reveals something more you have a
future in the past
years ago for me years from now for you
you know me for years they embarked on a
number of grand Adventures before Neil
finally met his end so sad
so what's happened during the Kiev Opera
Siege after watching tenants multiple
times we may have the answer our hero
the protagonist arrives at a stage
terrorist attack Satan's crew are
present in the form of Disguise SWAT
team members and are there to retrieve a
piece of the algorithm after which
they've planned to destroy any evidence
of its existence hence the bombs real
cops arrived to save the hostages
unaware that sata's men have infiltrated
their SWAT unit the protagonist who
infiltrated sata's fake SWAT unit thinks
he's there to steal parts of a nuclear
bomb after meeting with a mysterious man
in a box seat he learns the location of
a package rushes downstairs and acquires
what will ultimately be revealed as a
piece of the algorithm but for now he
doesn't really know what it is feeling
heroic the protagonist returns inside to
help the hostages runs into trouble and
then gets saved by another masked
individual only to end up getting
captured and tortured by tenet for his
troubles turns out it was all part of a
test a test you passed
not everybody does
that's one point joints and it's cat
reveals a moment in the past where she
witnessed a young woman jumping from her
husband's yacht in Vietnam since the
film deals with time travel most
audience members correctly guess the
mysterious woman's identity as some sort
of alternate cat but how did she get
there heavily referenced throughout the
film we're told that Santa's happiest
memory occurred some time ago in Vietnam
during which he and Kat enjoyed a
relaxing evening together on his yacht
future SATA Ventures back to this time
period while past Sater is at the Kiev
Opera to relive the memory before
killing himself and setting off events
that will cause the end of the world
luckily the protagonist Neil and Katz
deduce the time and place SATA will make
his last stand and send cat backwards
through time to arrive at that same
point while also simultaneously healing
her inverted bullet wound now it happens
that future SATA is a knowingly speaking
with future cats unaware that passcat
has already taken their son to shore
pascat then Witnesses Future Care to
dive off the yard following sata's
execution at the hands of future cat
presumab believe past Sater comes back
from Kiev and continues on with his life
unaware that his future self just died
in the past
he has a novel question for you how did
Satan not know his plan had failed he
travels back to the past in order to
execute his plan but since he still
exists in the future shouldn't he know
he went back in time and killed her and
grandfather how could you've been born
to commit the ACT what's the answer
there's no answer it's Paradox tenet
Works around this concept by applying a
whole new set of time travel rules as
explained by Esquire Christopher Nolan
utilizes the bootstrap Paradox or a
causal Loop in which an event causes
another to occur internet the
protagonist experiences the events of
the film then relays the acquired
information to Neil who travels back in
time to affect those events with this
acquired knowledge hence the second
event is causal to the first event due
to a loop Continuum simple right
according to the signpost Nick muanaka
and Darren Steed the characters are
stuck in a Time Loop and having already
gone back to stop SATA they are forced
to repeat stopping SATA
drawing the 747 Heist and crash sequence
at Oslo Freeport the protagonist and
they all come across two doors with a
red and blue marker differentiating them
inside they find what appears to be the
scene of a crime there are bullet holes
in the glass gun parts scattered on the
floor and smoke hanging in the air the
olasa's partner what's happened
prompting the protagonist to reply that
it hasn't happened yet suddenly a masked
man leaps from both turnstiles with all
of the mysterious individuals actions
being inverted the protagonist has
attacked one Neil is involved in a Chase
later we discovered that the inverted
Mass man is actually a future version of
the protagonist he and Neil went back to
this moment to use the turnstile in
order to uninvert themselves and return
to the normal time flow Our Heroes
inverted themselves in order to save CAD
from sata's gunshot wound following the
Talon freeway Chase they also needed to
go back to subsetsu at stalsk's 12.
however in order to keep from disrupting
the past and in service to the
aforementioned bootstrap Paradox the
protagonist has to use a Turn Style
without being Same by his past self so
although he desperately tries to flee
his counterpart he must engage in combat
to escape
Neil and the protagonists have a long
and complicated history when they first
meet up Neil seems to know a great deal
about his new partner right down to the
type of soda he prefers Diet Coke he's
also quick to trust the protagonist
despite a relatively brief introductory
period turns out the pair have actually
worked together for some time just not
in normal terms at the end of the film
Neil explains at this moment marks the
beginning of their relationship except
we know in order to save his friend Neil
is about to head off to certain death
for following this exchange what gives
informal looking at their relationship
from a chronological perspective the
protagonists we see at the end of the
film presumably travels back in time to
begin tenet and recruit Neil future
protagonist and past kneeled and enjoy a
series of Adventures before the former
passes Neil off to his younger self this
is why Neil was able to save the
protagonist at the Kiev our Prestige and
during the stalks 12 battle because he
already knew it was going to happen
based on information relayed to him by
his partner from the future as explained
by Insider Neil is stuck in a closed
loop doomed be the events of tenets over
and over always leading to his death as
Neil States what happens happened
in the climactic battle that stalsk 12
much is happening explosions gunfire
helicopters collapsing buildings most of
which is inverted visually Christopher
Nolan doesn't do enough to differentiate
the good guys from the bad which
sometimes leaves us more confused than
elated after repeated viewings here's
what we know is happening during the
grand finale two private armies and
leave with tenets run through separate
time periods in an attempt to create a
diversion so that the protagonist Neil
and Ives can secure the algorithm the
Red Sea moves normally through time
while The Blue Team waits for the battle
to result in the big explosion which is
designed to bury the algorithm The Blue
Team then participates in the madness in
Reverse both teams unleash some serious
Firepower and incur plenty of artillery
themselves we see people die but we
don't ever get a good look at the enemy
the CIA Handler at the beginning of the
film doesn't mean he's not exactly sure
who satsa is hiring to do his bidding
however he does allude to the
possibility of them being Russian
mercenaries which makes sense
considering Style 12 as part of a
collection of closed Russian cities in
the end all that matters is that Neil
and the protagonists succeed which they
do after supposedly slaughtering
hundreds of unseen bad guys so you can
let your imagination fill in all the
bloody details
tenet comes packed with a bunch of
scientific jargon that may be too hard
to understand on the initial viewing but
here's a hint that may help you turn on
the subtitles one such bit of mumbo
jumbo involves something called a
temporal pincer which is just a fancy
way of describing a mission that
utilizes inversion we get a good look at
a temporal Pinsir in the action-packed
finale during which two teams tackle the
same battle from different directions in
time the red team executes their mission
by moving forward while The Blue Team
waits for the mission to end before
inverting and fighting the same battle
backwards we see smaller temporal pins
has occur throughout the film such as
drawing the freeway Chase and the 747
Heist but did you know the entirety of
tenant is actually one large temporal
pincer operation we learn as much during
the closing scenes where it's revealed
the protagonist as the one behind
everything and we mean everything tennis
the operation Neil all of it after
experiencing the events of the film he
goes back in time and sets up a much of
the film's actions in order to fulfill
the time Loop the protagonist instructs
people to execute Pacific events for
example Neil saving him at the Key of
Opera and later allowing himself to be
kidnapped tortured and recruited by the
Senate's organization he's not altering
the past per se but executing it the way
it's supposed to be executed as
previously established as in the film
perhaps the best way to understand is to
go back and watch it again with the
benefit of having been there before
[Music]